qu'est la politique de formation sur le
campus de schoelcher avec qui et dans
quel contexte surtout avec ce dossier du
ciraig miam
difficile de faire plus court odile
marcellin france progrès bonjour bonjour
monsieur vient le temps et bonjour à
toute la martinique
la vie serait président du pôle
martinique de l'université des antilles
qui est dans ce sens qu a dit hier
madame barcelone france progrès vous
avez débuté des ateliers de réflexion
pour établir cette tarte de formation
que proposera l'université des antilles
au cours des prochaines années 5
ateliers en taux et le premier a porté
sur la biodiversité environnement
anthropisés faut-il préciser
l'importance de ces ateliers pour les
jeunes martiniquais pour les jeunes
antillais
alors tout d'abord une précision il
s'agit pour nous au niveau de
l'université des antilles de définir la
politique de sites anti de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche pour les cinq prochaines
années et donc dans ce cadre nous avons
depuis juillet 2016 démarrer une
réflexion qui intègre l'ensemble des
partenaires du territoire mais également
les institutions donc la collectivité
territoriale de martinique et l'état le
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
dans le cadre d'une dune positionnement
effectivement de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche de
l'innovation et du transfert de
technologie pour les cinq prochaines
années
l'incident qui décident de ce qui se
passe quand termes de formation le site
compte il comprend la martinique et la
guadeloupe
donc nous menons des ateliers
thématiques qui sont fait également
simultanément en guadeloupe sur donc des
thématiques qui ont été identifiées
défini et avec l'ensemble des
partenaires
les socioprofessionnels les institutions
les associations et bien nous nous
sommes en train de travailler à savoir
quels sont donc les filières que nous
allons privilégier de développement pour
la martinique que nous allons
privilégier et dans le cadre des snow
ces filières nous mettons en évidence
des chaînes de valeur en matière de
formation en matière de recherche en
matière d'innovation en matière de
transfert de technologie pour
effectivement amené le développement
économique de nos territoires s'agit de
répondre aux besoins des entreprises
martiniquaises dans des filières qui
sont promises à de l'avenir
il s'agit de répondre effectivement aux
besoins des entreprises mais également
aux besoins des institutions des
territoires d'une façon générale et
l'objectif c'est bien sûr d'amener donc
de la valeur ajoutée de permettre
également l'emploi de nos jeunes et
notamment en matière de formation
il y à une réflexion qui est menée en
partenariat avec les acteurs du monde
socio-économique pour qu'on puisse
mettre en place les vrais les vraies
formations qui répondent aux vrais
besoins de nos sociétés aujourd'hui pour
fixer cette jeunesse martiniquaise ici
même dans son pays ses travaux audii la
marionnette françois regrets sont quand
même parasité par le contexte encore
cette affaire de détournements présumés
de fonds au sein du laboratoire de
recherche de ces réunions le rappel 3tc
dirigeants écartés sanctionnés pour leur
rôle présumé dans ce dossier et tout à
coup de théâtre
l'avocat de l'université qui préconise
le retour sur le site dans un souci
d'apaisement qu'est ce que vous en dites
vous et bien la semaine dernière quand
j'ai appris sur les ondes et que j'ai vu
le nouvel avocat de l'université
s'exprimer parce que nous n'étions pas
informés de cela je dois dire que trois
sentiments mon agitée d'abord
l'indignation ensuite l'inquiétude
et puis ensuite des interrogations alors
l'indignation parce que nous sommes dans
le cadre d'une affaire qui est en cours
une affaire pénale qui est en cours il y
a eu donc la sphère administrative là
la justice administrative qui est passé
une sanction qui a été donc annulé par
la cour de cassation
mais j'insiste c'est sur des questions
de forme
donc l'affairé sera à nouveau jugé et
maintenant nous avons appris donc à la
fin de l'année dernière que le juge
d'instruction avait reconduit
l'interdiction de venir sur le campus
pour les protagonistes de l'affairé en
cours et nous apprenons aujourd'hui que
dans un souci d'apaisement
l'avocat en fait tu laisserais faire
finalement la la si l'avocat le dis
c'est que le président est aux gens qui
le permet alors effectivement un avocat
un avocat en fait il défend il défend
son client et donc l'avocat se fait le
porte parole de ce que le président de
l'université lui devant lui demande
alors qu'elle est là nous sommes
vraiment très inquiets parce que il faut
bien savoir qu'il s'agit de présomptions
de détournements de fonds sont très
importants la réalité c'est que nous
avons déjà remboursé 6 millions d'euros
que nous avons deux millions d'euros qui
sont en réserve qu'on ne peut pas
toucher et la réalité que nous vivons
aujourd'hui c'est le fait que nous ne
pouvons pas mettre en oeuvre des projets
de formation des projets de recherche
des projets de réhabilitation de nos
campus des projets de sécurisation de
nos campus des projets pour nos
étudiants de vie étudiante et ça c'est
extrêmement grave
le président est agent qui fait-il
preuve d'inconscience dans un dossier
explosif et et dans ce dernier coup de
théâtre qui a mis le feu aux poudres
puisqu'on a vu les réactions un peu
partout alors il y a de l'indignation
mais il ya également de l'inquiétude
gillet collègues et des membres de la
communauté universitaire qui sont
extrêmement inquiets parce que nous
avons besoin vous le constatez fait
kilomètres au delà c'est encore le voir
effectivement faire repartir notre
université il pendant quatre ans a
souffert et nous ne souhaitons pas
souffrir à nouveau deux de ses
difficultés que nous avons eues au
niveau de l'université
nous avons des projets en cours nous
avons d une politique de site à m
en place nous avons à restaurer la
confiance avec le monde socio économique
avec les profits avec les professionnels
et donc pour cela en question
nous devons nous montrer exemplaire nous
devons nous montrer exemplaire également
vis-à-vis de notre jeunesse
comment supposer que nous accepterions
d'en remettre face à des étudiants des
personnes qui sont encore dans une dans
le cadre d'une procédure pénale en cours
il y à la présomption d'innocence que
nous avons besoin d'avoir les réponses
de neuf ans avant de nous repositionner
disant pas en cause est ce que vous
pourriez vous faire l'avocat du diable
et vous dirais bien après tout la
justice n'a pas définitivement tranché
il n'y a pas encore de procès donc ces
personnes sont présumées innocentes
bien sûr elles sont présumées innocentes
mais elles sont également présumé
coupable
donc tant que la justice ne s'est pas
prononcé il y à un risque très important
de remettre des troubles au niveau de
nos campus université nos étudiants des
étudiants reviennent vers moi sont
inquiets ce sont des personnes qui se
sont toutes au moins pour l'un des
protagonistes exprimé très clairement
sûr sûr sûr un retour pas du tout pour
mettre en place pour être dans une
dynamique de sérénité et de calme au
niveau de nos campus est donc en tant
que vice présidente de l'université du
pôle universitaire de la martinique je
me dis cela je me désolidarise
complètement de ces propos qui sont
tenus par un avocat qui est censé nous
défendre quand je sais les conséquences
aujourd'hui pour notre établissement
des fonds que nous avons dû rembourser
alors l'avez vous dis au président de
l'université qu'il fait erreur selon
vous selon une grande partie de la
communauté du campus de schoelcher et au
vu des réactions suscitées dans des
sphères qui quand même des passes
l'université alors nous interrogeant le
président donc nous avons une première
instance qui s'est réunie que le
président donc présidait la question a
été posée au président concernant
effectivement le positionnement de
l'université vis-à-vis des propos tenus
par par le
ce nouvel avocat que nous avons
découvert par les médias je tiens quand
même à le préciser et nous n'avons pas
de réponse le président ne nous
répondent pas refuse de nous répondre
c'est la situation actuelle dans
laquelle nous sommes aujourd'hui c'est
encore une pierre de plus dans cette
relation tumultueuse du que
conflictuelle que vous que vous cultivez
avec lui alors peut-être personnalisé
sur l'épaule martinique et la présidence
actuellement en guadeloupe ne savait pas
de situations conflictuelles je
parlerais plutôt de l'université à
construire de d'une autonomie des pôles
universitaires qui est donc prévu un
dans la halle par la loi qui est prévu
par les statuts de l'université à mettre
en place
c'est l'un des principes fondateurs de
l'univers c'était le prêt le premier
principe fondateur de la construction de
l'université des antilles c'est un
établissement une unité d'établissement
mais le deuxième principe c'est
l'autonomie des pôles universitaires
pour éviter justement qu'on se retrouve
dans ses difficultés que nous avons
connues lors de la de la rupture avec
avec la guyane et donc il s'agit de
mettre en place une véritable
concertation entre le président et les
vice-présidents de paul puisque
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de la loi de
nouvelles prérogatives sont dévolues au
pôle universitaire notamment les pôles
universitaires doivent mettre en oeuvre
en fait leur autonomie en matière
stratégique en matière également
d'organisations financières et
administratives
oui ou non en de bourse cette unité peut
voler en éclats avec cette affaire du
seigneur je ne pense pas que l'unité va
voler en éclats parce que nous sommes
une université mais surtout nous devons
nous positionner fermement par rapport à
notre jeunesse qu'une oie garde
aujourd'hui et pour lesquels nous devons
être exemplaires
merci
odile marcellin france progrès
présidente du vice président du pôle
martinique de l'université des antilles
merci bonne journée
merci à vous
[Musique]